when the sun rises here in southern
kenya elephants make their way to the
watering hole
no matter what season it is in the
satellite conservancy they can count on
finding water
the private conservation area is home to
a diverse flora and fauna
the elephants and other species like
zebra and wildebeest use the corridor to
migrate between tanzania and kenya
however human settlement and agriculture
posed a threat to the ecosystem
in order to protect the wildlife the
african wildlife foundation decided to
partner with a local maasai community
i think it's long been recognized that
government alone cannot effectively
steward natural resources
i'm people have begun to talk about the
need for involving the local people who
live
and depend on the natural resources in
the conservation of those resources i
think that's a much more sustainable
land of conservation
together with the african wildlife
foundation the maasai devised a land use
plan
now one part of the area is reserved for
agriculture and settlement and another
part is reserved for conservation
a small luxury lodge was set up to
develop tourism
at several hundred euros a night a room
here doesn't come cheap
yet the lodge attracts tourists from all
over the world
the environment the the majestic
mountain hook sunderland comes up yeah
it's always beautiful
and certainly in the early morning hours
when it's just there in its in its
grandeur area
and
the environment is just stunning typical
amboseli look the elephants in a row
kilimanjaro behind
it's holiday yeah
the lodge not only benefits wildlife and
tourists it also benefits the community
the lodge has earned the community over
470 000 euros so far
part of the revenue is used to fund
community projects such as a school a
well and husbandry services
the lodge also trains and employs about
25 members of the local community
i'm one of the beneficiaries of this
program
i make the beads you see at the souvenir
shop at the lodge
we bought those with money we got from
the lodge because i'm one of the
shareholders
since the lodge was set up many locals
have become more environmentally aware
what used to be viewed as a threat is
now regarded as a valuable source of
income
mostly i personally love elephants
i love them because when most tourists
come here they come to see the elephants
and truthfully
even in the conventions we've attended
we see that the elephant has the most
value
so we're more protective over them than
we are of the other animals
solving human wildlife conflicts isn't
easy
but the lri conservancy shows that it is
possible
protected areas make up one tenth of
kenya's territory and the human
population keeps on increasing
so it's crucial to find solutions that
benefit both humans and wildlife